♪ ♪
>> Tucker: WELL, IN A FEW
DAYS, AND YOU WILL SEE IT HERE
ON FOX, JOE BIDEN IS GOING TO
ACCEPT HIS PRESIDENTIAL
NOMINATION.
AT THE SAME TIME, ALONE IN HER
APARTMENT, GOVERNOR WILL DO THE
VERY SAME THING.
SHE WANTS TO THANK YOU FOR THE
IMPRESSIVE LEVEL OF SUPPORT SHE
RECEIVED.
SHE LOOKS FORWARD TO RUNNING
THIS COUNTRY.
NOW, SHE WILL NOT BE ALLOWED TO
SAY THAT FROM THE STAGE OF THE
DNC.
THE WHOLE POINT OF THE
CONVENTION IS TO HIGHLIGHT A
PARTY’S MOST POPULAR POSITION
WHILE KEEPING ITS CRAZIES HIDDEN
FROM PUBLIC VIEW.
BUT WHAT IF SUDDENLY EVERYONE IN
THE PARTY GOES CRAZY?
WHAT IF THERE ARE NO SANE PEOPLE
LEFT?
THEN, YOU GET WHAT WE ARE SEEING
RIGHT NOW.
DEMOCRATS SPENT THE LAST WEEK
OUTLINING A CONSPIRACY THAT
LOOKS SO DANGEROUS THAT IT MAKES
RUSSIA LOOK LIKE JAYWALKING.
THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES IS WORKING TO
ELIMINATE THE U.S. MAIL.
THAT DOESN’T JUST MEANING CLOSE
IN THE POST OFFICE.
NO, IT IS FAR WORSE THAN THAT
AND MUCH SNEAKIER.
TRUMP IS STEALING THE MAILBOXES.
DRIVING THROUGH DEMOCRATIC
NEIGHBORHOODS IN THE MIDDLE OF
THE NIGHT, TOSSING THEM IN THE
BACK OF A STATION WAGON,
CACKLING LIKE THE LOUD MAN HE
IS.
EITHER WAY, IT’S THE SAME.
WITH NO MAILBOXES, DEMOCRATS
WON’T BE ABLE TO VOTE.
DONALD TRUMP IS STEALING THE
ELECTION.
AND HERE’S THE THING, DEMOCRATS
CAN’T CALL TO COMPLAIN ABOUT IT.
IT SEEMS THAT SOMEONE TOOK ALL
THE PAY PHONES TOO.
CAN YOU IMAGINE?
APPARENTLY, IT WAS ALL THERE.
BIDEN WAS SO UPSET.
HE WAS STILL RANTING ABOUT IT
DURING A VIRTUAL FUND-RAISER ON
FRIDAY.
HE TOLD THE CROWD, "THEY ARE
GOING AROUND LITERALLY WITH
TRACTOR-TRAILERS PICKING UP
MAILBOXES.
YOU WANT TO GO ONLINE AND CHECK
OUT WHAT THEY ARE DOING IN
OREGON.
I MEAN, IT’S BIZARRE.
LITERALLY WITH TRACTOR-TRAILERS
IN ORGAN.
THE FUNNY THING IS, OREGON
HASN’T VOTED FOR REPUBLICAN IN A
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION IN MORE
THAN 25 YEARS.
IT’S UNCLEAR WHAT EXACTLY TRUMP
MIGHT BE GAINING.
BUT WHATEVER.
IT’S JUST WRONG.
FORMER VICE PRESIDENT, AL GORE,
WENT ON CNN THE OTHER DAY TO
MAKE THAT POINT.
>> TAMPERING WITH THE POSTAL
SERVICE, PUTTING HIS KNEE ON THE
NECK OF AMERICAN DEMOCRACY.
>> Tucker: STEALING MAILBOXES,
SAYS AL GORE, IS NOTHING LESS
THAN TRUMP PUTTING HIS KNEE ON
THE NECK OF DEMOCRACY.
THE BLOOD IS DRAINING FROM
AMERICA’S FACE.
AS YOU CAN IMAGINE, THIS CAUGHT
THE MEDIA’S ATTENTION.
WITHOUT PAUSING TO SEE IF IT WAS
TRUE, THEY RUSHED TO THEIR
CAMERAS TO REPEAT IT.
>> ESSENTIAL SORTING MACHINES
REMOVED.
NEW MAILBOXES LITERALLY HAULED
AWAY ON FLATBED TRUCKS.
>> MAILBOXES BEING PICKED UP.
WHAT IS THAT ABOUT OTHER THAN
VOTER SUPPRESSION?
SPEAK ABOUT THE PROBLEM.
>> PEOPLE ARE WORRIED ABOUT THE
POST OFFICE.
YOU SEE THAT MAILBOXES ARE BEING
TAKEN AWAY PEER WHAT’S GOING ON?
>> THE REMOVAL OF EQUIPMENT
WITHIN THE POST OFFICES IS TO
UNDERMINE THE POSTAL SERVICE AT
A TIME WHEN THE POSTAL SERVICE
IS NEEDED MORE THAN EVER.
>> ARE YOU LISTENING TO THIS?
THEY ARE HAULING AWAY AMBULANCES
ON FLATBED TRUCKS.
HIS BOSS, NANCY PELOSI AGREES
WITH THAT.
NANCY PELOSI CAN ACTUALLY DO
SOMETHING ABOUT IT.
THAT’S WHY SHE IS IN CHARGE.
SHE ANNOUNCED THAT SHE IS
CALLING BACK CONGRESS FROM
SUMMER VACATION.
NANCY PELOSI SAID IT IS TIME FOR
A LEGISLATURE OF --
SHE IS TRYING TO "SABOTAGE THE
ELECTION BY ELIMINATING THE
POSTAL SERVICE."
WITH NO POSTAL SERVICE, PELOSI
SAID, SENIORS MAY NOT BE ABLE TO
GET THEIR SOCIAL SECURITY CHECKS
IN THE MAIL.
NOW, NANCY PELOSI IS 80 YEARS
OLD, SO YOU WOULD THINK THAT SHE
WOULD KNOW THAT THE GOVERNMENT
HASN’T USED THE POSTAL SERVICE
TO SEND THOSE CHECKS SINCE 2013.
ALL, IN OTHER WORDS WE CAN BE
PRETTY SURE THAT NANCY PELOSI
DOESN’T LIVE ON HER
SOCIAL SECURITY BENEFITS.
BUT DON’T TELL THE REST OF THE
HOUSE DEMOCRATS.
THEY ARE RILED UP.
SOMEONE CALLED FOR THE FBI TO
INVESTIGATE THE POSTMASTER
GENERAL.
NOT LONG AFTER THEY SHARED THAT,
THEY SHOWED UP OUTSIDE OF HIS
HOUSE.
]HORN SOUNDING]
>> Tucker: THIS IS A BIG
STORY.
SO, THE QUESTION IS, WHO IS
STEALING ALL OF THOSE MAILBOXES?
IT’S ACTUALLY AN INTERESTING
TALE IF YOU GET INTO THE DETAILS
OF IT.
CONSIDER A RECENT TWEET FROM
NEW JERSEY CONGRESSMAN, NIKKI
CHERYL, WHO MAY NOT BE THE
SMARTEST MEMBER OF CONGRESS.
SHE POSTED A PHOTO OF HER TRUCK
FILLED WITH MAILBOXES.
IT IS BEING SYSTEMATICALLY
DISMANTLED HERE IN NEW JERSEY
AND AROUND THE COUNTRY.
THEN A FEW YEARS DAYS LATER, SHE
AT LEAST ONE HAS BEEN REPLACED.
WE WILL CONTINUE TO PROVIDE MORE
INFORMATION AS WE HAVE IT.
NIKKI CHERYL IS LIKE HER OWN
24-HOUR NEWS SERVICE.
JUST LIKE CNN, SHE DIDN’T BOTHER
TO CHECK YOUR FACTS BEFORE GOING
ON AIR.
FORMER NATIONAL SECURITY
ADVISOR, SUSAN RICE, DID DO SOME
REPORTING ON THE SUBJECT.
SHE CLAIMED THAT MAILBOXES WERE
BEING REMOVED TO SUPPRESS
DEMOCRATIC VOTERS.
SUSAN RICE’S TWEET WAS SHARED BY
MORE THAN 30,000 PEOPLE.
A LOT OF AMERICAN SIDE.
AS A MATTER OF FACT, WE TRY TO
STICK TO FACTS.
NOBODY IS STEALING AMERICAN’S
MAILBOXES.
THIS IS ANOTHER HOAX.
IT’S ANOTHER LIE.
IT WAS TOTALLY MADE UP IN ORDER
TO MANIPULATE.
THE POST OFFICE MOVES MAILBOXES
AS A MATTER OF COURSE AND HAS
FOR MANY YEARS.
DONALD TRUMP DID NOT ORDER THIS.
IT IS NORMAL.
FOR 2017 REPORT FROM THE USPS
INSPECTOR GENERAL, FOR EXAMPLE
KNOWS THAT THE POSTAL SERVICE
HAS REMOVED 14,000 DELL BOXES
OVER THE PRECEDING FIVE YEARS.
THIS HAS BEEN GOING ON SINCE AT
LEAST 2009.
2009 WAS THE SAME YEAR, BY THE
WAY, THAT BARACK OBAMA WHO
PRESIDED OVER THIS MAILBOX
REMOVAL DELIVERED THE FOLLOWING
ASSESSMENT OF THE U.S. MAIL.
>> PEOPLE SAY WELL, HOW CAN A
PRIVATE COMPANY COMPETE AGAINST
THE GOVERNMENT?
IF YOU THINK ABOUT IT, UPS AND
FEDEX OFFICE IS ALWAYS HAVING
PROBLEMS.
>> Tucker: WAIT, WHAT?
DID YOU HEAR THAT?
TALK ABOUT AN UNINSPECTED TWIST.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN, THE GREAT
MAILBOX CONSPIRACY OF 2020 TURNS
OUT TO BE BIGGER AND MORE
COMPLEX THAN WE REALIZE.
BARACK OBAMA IS IN ON IT TOO.
SO WHAT IS THIS REALLY ABOUT IN
REAL LIFE?
WELL, LAST WEEK, THE PRESIDENT
REFUSED TO HAND OVER
$3.5 BILLION TO THE POSTAL
SERVICE IN A RECENT NEGOTIATION.
THAT WAS MONEY THAT WOULD GO
TOWARD MAIL IN VOTING.
THIS IS WHAT THEY ARE MAD ABOUT.
THAT WAS A BLOW TO ONE OF
NANCY PELOSI’S TOP PRIORITIES.
DEMOCRATS FAVOR MAIL IN VOTING.
THEY FAVOR ANY VOTING THAT DOES
NOT ENTAIL ACTUAL VOTERS GOING
TO AN ACTUAL POLLING PLACE.
IT IS NOT A CIVIL RIGHTS ISSUE.
VOTES CAST BY MAIL ARE EASIER TO
TAMPER WITH.
THE IDENTITIES OF VOTERS WHO
CAST THEM ARE HARDER TO VERIFY.
MAIL IN VOTING MAKES VOTER FRAUD
EASIER.
THAT’S WHY WE HAVEN’T HAD A LOT
OF IT THROUGHOUT AMERICAN
HISTORY AND THAT’S WHY DEMOCRATS
ARE FOR IT.
WE HAVE SEEN FRAUD.
THERE IS NO MAIL AND VOTER
FRAUD.
JUST IN THE PAST FEW MONTHS, FOR
EXAMPLE, WEST VIRGINIA.
PLEADED GUILTY TO ALTERING MAIL.
THE USPS FOUND HUNDREDS OF
BALLOTS IN A SINGLE MAILBOX FROM
LOCAL CITY COUNCIL.
MORE THAN 200,000 MAIL AND VOTES
FROM THE RECENT PRIMARY ELECTION
HAVE BEEN DECLARED
UNDELIVERABLE.
THOSE ARE LOCAL AND STATEWIDE.
IMAGINE THIS ON A NATIONAL SCALE
DURING A PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION.
IMAGINE IT’S MAGNIFIED ACROSS 50
STATES.
WHAT WOULD BE THE EFFECT OF
THAT?
WELL, THERE WOULD BE NO WAY TO
ENSURE THE INTEGRITY OF THE
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION.
OH, RIGHT, THAT’S PRECISELY THE
POINT.
IN JULY, "THE BOSTON GLOBE"
DESCRIBED HOW A GROUP OF BIDEN
OFFERS HAD A SECRET WAR GAME IN
WHICH THEY GAVE UP THE
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION THIS FALL.
THEY DESCRIBED ONE SCENARIO IN
WHICH HE TOOK BIDEN’S ROLE.
"HE SHOCKED THE ORGANIZERS BY
SAYING HE FELT HIS PARTY WHEN IT
LET HIM --
HE PERSUADED THEM TO SEND PRO
BIDEN ELECTORS.
OH, NOT CRAZY.
AMERICANS "STOPPED LOOKING TO
THE MEDIA AND WAITED TO SEE WHAT
THE MILITARY WOULD DO.
SO, JOHN IS GAMING OUT HOW THE
UNITED STATES MILITARY COULD PUT
JOE BIDEN IN OFFICE.
AND THAT TELLS YOU A LOT ABOUT
HOW DEMOCRATS ARE THINKING ABOUT
THIS ELECTION.
MAKING UP AS OUR STORIES ABOUT
HOW DONALD TRUMP STEALS
MAILBOXES MAY BE LUDICROUS, BUT
STORIES LIKE THAT MAKE AMERICA
EVEN MORE PARANOID AND FEARFUL
THAN IT ALREADY IS.
AND THAT’S THE POINT.